That’s quite a background.
Well, up to now the President's gambit on
Cuba has been pretty much a debacle.
It's been a one-sided affair.
He's showering concessions on the regime,
and getting really nothing in return.
But I'm not totally pessimistic about his
visit because I think he can salvage this
Cuba initiative by going to Cuba, going to
Havana, insisting on a national platform,
some sort of national broadcast, and posing
to the regime this challenge: "Let Cubans
vote.”
Let them decide their future.
That's really the problem up to now.
I think the President didn't understand that
the real problem in Cuba was not U.S. policy
but the fact that the regime is a totalitarian
regime that's bent on holding onto power.
If he makes that challenge, it will really
be a historic moment.
It will be like Reagan saying: "Tear down
this wall."
And a great opportunity for the Cuban people
to see the Americans as friends and seize
this opportunity.
What are your ideas about empowering the Cuban
people.
Please offer your comments and give us ideas
about topics you’d like us to cover in the
future.